Good morning believe nation! Today's message is LOVE what you do
Over to you Matt Damon
I wake up every mornin'
Entspresso keep me goin'
You know, and the first job I got was, a real job besides commercials and things like that
local radio commercials and things that kind of gave us the money
Ben and I had a joint bank account and we'd go to New York
And if you had made money acting, it went into the account
And the account was to be used if you were going to New York for an audition
Or if we took ten dollars out to like play video games, okay? (laugh out loud) and uh
I got a line in the movie 'Mystic Pizza' and the line was "Mom do you want my green stuff?" and literally
But it was a scene that was a big dinner table scene. Julia Roberts, it was like a big movie for her
And uh it was this whole dinner table scene, and so it took us three nights to shoot
down in Mystic, Connecticut. And I was a minor so my mother had to come with me
And, you know, we shot from five to five every night
And uh and, I just remember being so in love with the process of filming
I just knew, I was like this is the greatest, it was the best time I'd ever had in my life
And it was, you know, I was like this is amazing. I want this to never ever ever stop
Like I loved it
So this is the message that's been repeated over and over and over again on the channel
From actors to musicians, to entrepreneurs, to investors, to politicians, to athletes, to like all over the place
The people who are at the top of there field love what they do
And it feels like it's another video saying the same thing
But it's just so important. And I feel like so many people are not doing what they love
So many people are doing the things that they feel like they have to do, or that just pays the bills
And they've shut off that part of themselves where they really enjoy the work that they're doing
And not everyday is gonna be amazing, and not every task you do is gonna be awesome
But net net that's gotta be enough of what you're doing on a daily basis that you love
If you're gonna have any kind of real success in this world
And I encourage you to explore until you find the thing that you just can't stop doing
You know, for Matt Damon, it was doing acting
For me, I remember doing a speech helping some young entrepreneurs out of the YMCA
And you know, only three people showed up, and I've told this story a number of times
But, I just felt so good. I can get lost in having discussions with entrepreneurs
And it just is so rewarding and amazing and fulfilling and for me as someone who's an introvert, believe it or not
who doesn't need to be surrounded by people, who needs to have time by himself
but if I find out that you are an entrepreneur, I am hooked. And I wanna help you
And I wanna get you where you wanna go, and I wanna know what your dream is
And I wanna know what impact you wanna have. I just get so fired up
It's a thing that makes me come alive the most. And I'm so grateful that I've discovered that
And I encourage you to go out and find that for yourself if you haven't already
Or if you have before and you've lost some interest in it
then, what's the pivot, what's the change? So that the work that you're doing isn't just okay
but it's great! And you're working on something that's really inspiring you
and really pushing you to be better
I think people just settle too much
I think people just don't make their highest aspirations important enough
And so you settle for good, and you have a good life
And you know, the goals you have are okay, and if you don't reach them, you know, whatever
And you just settle too much
Where when you find something that you truly love
You will push yourself beyond what you thought was possible
to create something no one even imagined before
And that is exciting. And I deeply, truly, hopefully, uh, want that for you as well
So the question to date today is 'What is it that you love the most doing? What is it that you can get lost in
And just feel the love of the work
Leave it in the comments below and I'm gonna join in the discussion
I also want to give a quick shout out to Oliver Candanedo
Oliver, thank you so much for buying my book
It means a lot to me
For those who are watching if you want a chance at a shout out in your future video
Make sure to pick up a copy of the book and e-mail in you receipt so we can keep track
Thank you guys so much for watching. Have an amazing day
Continue to believe for whatever your one word is
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning for another Shot! of Entspresso
I wake up every mornin'
Entspresso keep me goin'